[Applause]
it was the night of August 4th 1977
thousands of protesters gathered in San
Francisco and formed a human barricade
around this building to protect its
residents police are on their way now
police are on their way it was about
eleven o'clock and some inside person
called us and said they must be doing
something that eviction is probably
gonna happen
hundreds of police in riot gear forced
their way into a condemned hotel in San
Francisco today demonstrators formed a
human barricade but it did not prevent
police from using clubs and night sticks
their orders evict the last of the
people living there
[Applause]
for nearly ten years this building known
as the International Hotel had been at
the heart of a historic battle for fair
housing in San Francisco this is not
just a ordinary building you know what
was battles were fought right on that it
housed hundreds of Filipinos who fought
for their right to have a place to call
home in a city where they lived for
decades what happened that night changed
the community and the shape of the city
forever
[Music]
while it's now a part of Chinatown this
area used to be Manila town one of the
country's first Filipino American
communities but it wasn't your typical
immigrant community it was made up of
mostly men and that stemmed from a
relationship between the US and the
Philippines that ran deep after a brutal
war over a century ago the u.s.
colonized the Philippines and controlled
up until 1946 during that period two
major waves of Asian immigration
occurred in the u.s. first Chinese and
then largely Japanese migrants came to
the u.s. to work in mines factories on
railroads and on farms but over time
both Chinese and Japanese immigrants
faced racist backlash and were
eventually barred from entering the
country that created a demand for cheap
labor so the u.s. turned to a new group
Filipinos
in the 1920s and 30s the prospect of
financial security lured over 100,000
Filipino men to the US when the US took
over the Philippines they were American
nationals they felt like they were
living the American dream
but the reality of it was that they were
extremely exploited and wages were
really low exploitation had many forms
one of the most damaging repercussions
for Filipino men settling in the US was
isolation US policies kept the workers
from bringing their families over and
also stopped them from marrying white
women they did build roots I call it
social castration but this was a way of
again trying to keep them under control
and being able to abuse their lives and
that's where the gender imbalance begins
many of the Filipino men settled along
the west coast in San Francisco about
30,000 of them started forming a
community here on a ten block stretch
right along the spine of Chinatown on
Kearney Street it was the start of
Manila town outside of this area
Filipino workers found it hard to find
any affordable housing and that was by
design the city at large was strictly
racially segregated as soon as they
crossed the borders of Manila town like
here past Broadway and into surrounding
white communities they were shut out and
denied apartments and even if you walked
two blocks that way you could get beat
up even killed they had white seal
antique groups that would hunt them down
trying to take them out of town
that forced Filipino men to stay within
the boundaries of Manila town but
despite the constraints they found a way
to build a home for themselves
by the 1950s they were part of an entire
generation of aging men who
lived out their lives in the u.s. they
were called the Monde own generation ma
Nome is is a Filipino word it's a sign
of endearment and respect to an older
person in San Francisco's Manila town
many of the mono mended up living in
residential hotels like this one called
the International Hotel or I Hotel the
AI hotel housed nearly 200 people
largely Filipino men but some Chinese
men and women too they lived in confined
spaces often in poor conditions even so
the AI hotel and Manila town provided a
sense of community and belonging to the
residents there were parlors barber
shops places where people could play
pool just places where they could just
call home being around with we called
kebab lions like a brother so then the
hotel's become these places were it's
like family to them but their
neighborhood was caught in the middle of
a changing San Francisco San Francisco
has consistently been called one of the
most expensive cities in the world to
live with the influx of tech companies
in recent decades it struggled with
massive affordable housing shortages but
the problems of urbanization didn't
start with Silicon Valley it started in
the 1950s with what was called the
Manhattan ization of this heart of
downtown the city wanted a Wall Street
of the West and to make room for it they
came up with a master plan for the
redevelopment of San Francisco this plan
for urban renewal called low-income
neighborhoods blighted districts and
slums and asked for these areas to be
razed and rebuilt along modern lines
in the Western Addition and Fillmore
districts the city evicted around 12,000
largely black and Asian American
residents and here in the South of
Market area roughly 4,000 people were
evicted the residents of Manila town
right at the border of the growing
financial district knew they'd be
targeted next in 1968 the owner handed
the tenants of the eye hotel
their first eviction notice the real
estate company wanted to demolish the
building to make space for a parking lot
but the tenants resisted Filipino
community leaders and businesses joined
the fight along with a growing number of
local activists Estella was one of the
young activists on the front lines these
are pins from 1968 to 1984 and that's a
plug lava means fight for international
hotel after months of protests the owner
and tenants agreed to a new three-year
lease in 1969 but it was a temporary fix
by the 1970s redevelopment efforts moved
further and further into Manila town it
nearly swallowed the entire community
and threatened the I hotel once again
all the other hotels where many of the
other elderly lived were already being
demolished they were already being
evicted
so it was like domino and then some in
some ways
in 1973 the owner of the eye hotel sold
the building to a developer from
Thailand and that reignited the eviction
battle for the next four years inside
the court room and on the streets
protestors fought three more eviction
notices Asian American groups religious
groups labor rights groups and dozens of
others all came together in a show of
solidarity for low-income housing but
for Filipino residents it was also a
fight to claim what little space they
had in a city that was trying to erase
them in the summer of 1977 the tenants
of the I hotel were served another
eviction notice on August 3rd a news
reporter leaked information to tenants
and supporters that the police might
actually be coming that night the police
and the Sheriff's Department were
gathering it was still a threat but yet
we thought maybe this is it because if
they're gathering somewhere and it's in
the middle of the night it's probably
going to be a surprise I was the
president of the International Tennis
Association I felt that a lot of us felt
fear but I had to calm people I had to
tell them that this is what standing up
means we've met what was said well we're
not going to move you don't have to
carry yourself the sheriff's are just
simply going to have to drag us out of
this building they're going you know
that's on the night of August 4th tenant
leaders set off a red alert and over
2,000 protesters gathered on Kearney
Street many formed a human barricade
locking arms outside of the eye hotel
while others were stationed inside with
the remaining.i hotel tenants when the
police arrived on foot and on horses
they launched into the crowds with
batons I was upstairs inside the
building and so was email and we also
locked arms inside here when I started
hearing that
of the horses that's when I knew that it
was something was afoot it was really
scary
we had mattresses on the windows and on
the doors people were saying we won't
move we won't move
[Music]
[Applause]
eventually using a fire truck ladder the
police entered the building through the
roof and we hear shouting and screaming
from upstairs but because everything is
closed off it's kind of like muffled
once inside the police were confronted
by more protesters including a meal just
be enough dragged down the stairs
dragged down the street after making it
through the crowd of protesters the
police used axes to open up the doors to
rooms in the end to put a stop to this
rampage the tenants decided to stand
down they walked out one by one each
elder accompanied by an activist by the
next morning the streets were cleared
out
Emile's face was plastered all over the
national newspapers this is the actual
photo of an eviction I mean the next day
he sees in the New York Times and Boston
Globe I mean you see this all over
people carried from the building were
young demonstrators who had occupied
some of the vacant rooms tenants were
rushed out of the building many of them
so quickly they left everything behind
but the national attention was too late
it couldn't change what happened that
night or its repercussions the fight to
save the last remnant of Manila town was
shut down and the I Hotel tenants were
homeless the city claimed to have set up
replacement housing for the tenants but
there were no such accommodations that
was a lie it wasn't a place for them to
go they were kicked out into the street
we had to find makeshift places where
they could sleep some of them collapse
and I think what really saw more than
anything is how brokenhearted they were
because their family you know their
community was destroyed the I Hotel
remained vacant for nearly two years
before it was demolished tenants were
scattered throughout the city and Manila
town was destroyed we don't have the
presence in the city we've been here
over 100 years but we're overshadowed we
kind of still remain very invisible in
2005 nearly 30 years after the original
battle for the I hotel Manila town and
Chinatown activists accomplished a
decade's long effort to build a new AI
hotel today it contains 104 units of
dedicated affordable housing for senior
citizens this building carries the
legacy of its community and its struggle
one that still resonates in a city with
a deepening affordable housing crisis
the failure of the city always was that
they failed to build affordable housing
decent housing it's the failure of a
system that prioritizes property rights
over human rights I feel hopeful because
I know that there's a new generation
who's thinking about these things but
it's only possible if you have that idea
that housing is a human right
[Music]